[Music]
hi it's me amber ruffin from the amber
oven show
you guys the news was so crazy this week
that we kept having to change the script
for our show right up to the last minute
and
we even wrote a whole monologue that we
didn't end up using but
i thought you might want to see it so
here we go you ready turk i'm ready all
right let's do it
tuesday was election day and then a
groundhog saw its shadow and we got six
more weeks of election day
1.1 million new york city residents
voted early during this year's election
and those were just the rats
it's cute now you go you wonder oh
what's to scale
um the wall or the rats the wall is to
scale the rats are very big
they're very big that's what we're
saying well yeah those are human-sized
voting booths they're well-fed
one of the top five google searches made
during tuesday's election was
for liquor stores which i don't
understand because
trump's been president for four years
y'all don't have all the local liquor
stores memorized by now
if you're not drunk you're not paying
attention
according to i should drink during every
monologue yeah you should
just makes everything better according
to a new report americans are currently
leaving
in oops you know what
maybe i shouldn't drink maybe i should
according to a new report americans are
currently leaving the country in record
numbers
but how are they able to leave so easily
oh right he never finished it um yeah
they could just walk right now
just step right over yeah i mean it's
very spot now that
is not to scale no rats can just step
yeah a florida man recently paid the
owner of a private animal sanctuary
150 for a so-called
full-contact experience with a black
said the leopard fine but i don't kiss
on the mouth
i'm the black leopard who's coming
who's coming who's here today oh i'm
still in my robe oh
okay i'll be out 150 dollars
according to a new cdc study people who
have coronavirus
spread it to about half the people in
their house
this study was conducted on one house
a two-person kayak capsized in the
pacific ocean this week
after a humpback whale jumped out of the
water nearby
said the whale they just called michigan
for bidens
we are all that well and lastly
rapper kanye west received more than 60
000 votes in the presidential election
so finally we have a count of just how
many kardashians there are
sixty thousand and that was the
monologue we didn't get to use
[Music]
[Applause]
you